[音楽]
こんにちははじめしゃちょーですはい皆
さん本日はですねこちら
富士急ハイランドに来ておりますもう何度
お世話になったことかもう絶叫マシンで
いろんな企画させて頂いたり怖い場所あり
ますよね色んな企画何回もやらせて
いただいた大変お世話になっているテーマ
パークでございます今回なんですけれども
なんと新しい乗り物がついに
完成したということで
世界最速
史上初乗らせていただきます
ありがとうございます
圭介頑張れよまだどこも情報が出てない
らしくですねなんかガチの本当の最速
らしくてメディアさんとかよりも先も誰
よりも最速で乗ることができるみたいです
ありがとうございます
大丈夫でしょうか落ちたりしないでしょう
かちょっとだけがちょっと心配なんです
けれどもちょっと一番最初に乗れると
ありがたいよねそんな素敵なことないなと
思ってちょっと今回乗らせていただきます
もう実はね後ろにあるんですけれども
ちょっと見てみましょうかじゃあちょっと
見てみましょうか
こちら
[音楽]
です
すごくね見てまたこの開発
途中というかもうすぐ本当に完成なので今
いろいろ最終段階なのかなちょっと準備し
ていただいてるところですけども入り口
すごい見てなんか緑がテーマになってるん
かな
ぞっこん入り口と
絶叫優先権入口っていうただの優先権じゃ
ないのかこれ見て藤山とかと比べると高さ
すごいな藤山とか見てくださいこちらA
じゃないかとかもすごいこうグニャんって
なってる高さがあるんですけど
属痕見た感じ高さというよりなんか
グネグネかコースのグネグネ感が凄そうな
気がしてますちょっと中入る前にぐるっと
見てみましょうかこれかな
フォルツァみたいなそういうあのビスク
タイプの乗り物ですねこれ
バイク型なのか
っこいいね銀のこの
形式は誰かにゾッコンしたことある
これからです
どうですか俺は
常に続行だねを自分に
待って待って待って見て
コースないけど途中でこれなんかそういう
飛んじゃう感じですかこれどういうこと
制作途中ですか
レール引かれてないドッキリはやばい
でしょここ見るとなんかどういう感じなの
かちょっと
わかるかいやでもすごいぞ周り見てそこと
か
結構長くないぐねぐねすごいねなんか高さ
というよりこういうなんかグデグデの
コースがすごい続いてる感じですねで
なんとですね
こちらの
富士急さんの最新の乗り物ついさっき
45億円です
俺の家15個買った俺の家が15個食べ
ますこれ45億円45億の乗り物って
すごいよでさその高さを出してるわけでも
なくそういう角度がすごいとかでもない
からどこがどうなってるのがすごい気に
なるんですけども最高速度は
[音楽]
非公開らしいです
それはもう是非とも乗ってみて体験して
くれということで体感で俺伝えます
性格じゃないと思うんですけども
参考にしていただけると助かります
もう行くのこれ
見たいよねでも
俺絶対ダメなんですよこう見えて山場が何
個あると思うんです
よーんってなってるところもちょっと怖い
しそこまでねそこもすごいなんか
角度ついてそうレールの角度とかも一番
困るのはこのレールが途中で途切れてる
ところ
ジャンプアクションとかあるのこれ
ちょっと何にもまだ情報がないのでわかん
ないですけども早速ちょっと乗ってみたい
と思いますなんか入っていきましょう
すごい
めっちゃ可愛い花ある
すげーここに初でしょちょっと安全確認し
ながら行きますね
大丈夫
これちょっと閉めてもらっても大丈夫です
か
コースの
看板がありますね
ちょっとパッと見わからないけどラバー
ゾーンでマグマゾーンとかあるけど
大丈夫かなんかすぐに近未来感ある
メタリックな構造になってますね
そう
木の配列
均等に左右
均等に置かれてます木がおしゃれですね
駅のホームみたいな感じですね
かっこいい最新だねさあつきました
エントランスです
これが最終なんかこんなこと言われたら
すごい緊張しちゃうよねファイナル
チェックとか入れたら
やばい
いよいよって感じになってきたぞここで
普段だったらスタッフの方が安全に説明し
てくれる場所
らしいです
常に安全な姿勢を取って備えてください次
に安全な姿勢についてのご案内です
ポイントは2つ1つ目
商品を置いたまま乗ること2つ目ハンドル
につかまることハンドルに手が届かない方
は安全はありません
ありがとうございます
急加速系ねあーやばいもうあるあるある
ある
キャリア怪しいなピンクのネオンライト
っぽい
[音楽]
初だからねもう行くしかないやなこれは
じゃあ
乗ります
うち俺バイク乗ってたんでこの隙には慣れ
てはいるんですよ
それだけですね
行ってきますね
じゃあ行ってきます行ってきます
[拍手]
まずはこういう感じねはいはいはい
ゆっくり入ります
やばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばいやばい
やばい
[音楽]
終わったか
いや何が起きてたかあれでこれ大丈夫か
さっきと違うけど場所
えどういう
え
動いてる
今スライドして横になったぞ
今線路がなんかレールが横にスライドして
別のレールに変わりました
やばいやばいやばいやばい
今は気持ちいい福山で鍛えられて俺の精神
力かこれぐらいじゃ大丈夫です
もう終わりもう終わりかなもう終わりかな
これ
終わりかよかった
すごいな
面白いですねお疲れ様でした
史上初乗ってみました
最初の感想
楽しかったです
楽しかったもちろん怖かったよ
絶叫系苦手で怖かったけどバイクの姿勢な
のがすごい臨場感があって
バイク乗りとしてはすごい楽しかったです
本当にバイクでこの感じなんか
坂道走ってる感じこういうグニグニしてて
楽しかったのと線路ないとこで1回心臓
止まりました見てた逆走したの見た後ろで
走ってるそれがねすごい感覚だった
後ろ向きで外れジェットコースターとか
そんな俺に乗ったことなかったから
そこもびっくりしましたし体感速度はどう
だった体感速度一応
非公開となったんですけども僕の乗ってみ
た体幹速度5200kmでした
こだまです正直
藤山慣れしてるからかもしれないですけど
も
ちょうど良かった楽しめる速度もちろん
速いよ涙止まってなかったんですけどもう
1回乗ってって言われたら俺は乗りたいっ
て思っちゃうタイプのなんか
こんなに新しい普通のジェットコースター
だけではないっていうギミックがあって
すごい俺は楽しかったです次で富士急
ハイランドさんで45億円で作られた
新しい乗り物続墾7月の20日から乗れ
ますので皆さんぜひ乗ってみてください
いや俺はめっちゃ
好きだ藤山とこっちどっちに乗るって言わ
れたら俺はこっちを選びますちょっとまた
乗りたいですねこれはぜひバイク好きな人
とかバイク乗ってみたいなっていう人は
乗ってみたらいいかなと思います
お願いします
[音楽]